have you played call of duty World War  two and thought gee I really wish I  could spend more money on this game  well now you can I'm Tony and I'll try  to keep my sarcasm in check for this  GameSpot news update World War 2 now  lets you spend Call of Duty points to  get rare level supply drops in both  multiplayer and zombies modes you can  get 200 for 2 bucks  1,100 for 10 bucks 2400 for 20 bucks  5,000 for 30 bucks 9,500 for 75 bucks  and a whopping 13,000 for $100 we found  200 complementary points waiting for us  when we logged in so you might have a  gift waiting for you too next time you  go online micro transactions were meant  to come to Call of Duty World War 2  sooner but developer sledgehammer  delayed them to fix some of the game's  launch issues the game came to ps4 Xbox  one and PC at the start of the month and  it received a strong 9 out of 10 from  GameSpot you can check out that review  for more on the games campaign  multiplayer and zombies modes